at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of now I do have to
read a mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there's the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it
they've become massively popular just
take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller and I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99designs comm
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners you guys will get a free $99
upgrade on your first design that's
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
check it out greetings lads and lasses
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show I'm sitting at my kitchen
table with mr. Eric now I've always this
is embarrassing to say and I've done
this with a number of friends now is it
Weinstein Weinstein how do you say your
last name I think it's Weinstein
Weinstein I agree that's the more
Germanic way to go about it now I am
going to read a short bio I'm sure I'm
going to bastardize this because I
realized that we have so many
wide-ranging conversations and I was
wondering and asking myself where to
start and I realized there's no real
good place or no particular place to
start so you can start anywhere so I'll
start with your bio Eric Weinstein
managing director of tail capital PhD in
mathematical physics from Harvard
research fellow at the mathematical
Institute of Oxford University but as
you and I have discussed that does not
quite capture the eclectic combination
of life experiences that is Eric so what
are some other sort of colorful aspects
of this this collage Oh who's yourself
alright um so sometimes I I pretend to
be an immigration expert particularly
with respect to skilled labor I'm also a
member of the advisory board for a group
called drugs over dinner
trying to get a rational and healthy
drug policy for the US I was pretty
early on sounding the alarm over
mortgage backed securities and failed to
alert the world with a bunch of other
people who also failed but we gave it a
little college try guess that makes it
uncrowded trade it was well the problem
is that early is another name for wrong
yeah and also it you can't quite believe
what you're saying that Goldman Sachs
and the rest of the world is going to
blow up it's hard to have have the
courage of your convictions but o'cash I
mean I think have you taken a lot of
economics classes to inform all of these
insights I've dated women and married
them who have taken a lot of economics
classes so I haven't taken any
but in order to get some attention for
the work we've done in economics I
decided to start referring to myself as
an economist I figured if I got called
out then I would get to push the work in
front of a world that was asking for my
credentials and so strangely economists
don't call you out when you call
yourself an economist and so I ended up
as an economist rather than having the
attention that I was hoping to drag to
this new theory of gauge theoretic and
geometric economics and to to provide
just a little bit of context which i
think is fairly normal for our
interactions so I'm just going to read
one line from an email exchange and this
is from Eric to me do you want to try a
podcast on this and we'll get into maybe
what this is psychedelics theories of
everything and the need to destroy
education in order to save it how did we
first meet was it Summit Series was it
somewhere else I think it was somewhat
serious I think you were talking about
the potential of the human mind and how
to unlock it and I think I became very
curious as to what the domain of
applicability was and whether some of
these techniques that would help you
shoot baskets or learn tango could be
applied to let's say quantum field
theory which seemed like kind of the
next logical place to go after tango
dancing and I think many people would
ask themselves managing director of Kiel
Capital so how does someone who from a
lay person's perspective is a
mathematician pretending to be an
economist very effectively ready to be a
mathematician pretending to be a
mathematician I get recruited and end up
working with Peter Thiel till capital
it's a really good question I knew Peter
slightly before geez we are gonna be
just entering at a random point so it's
quite good the best I attempt I can in
trying to be quantum so I had I had met
Peter when I I had been sort of living
in New York and playing in the
area a little bit with the tech crowd
and I was told by some friends you have
to come out for this crazy being human
conference and so any conference name
being human seemed to Californian to be
a good idea but I was forced into coming
out and there was a sort of a circle of
people which Peter was in and I was in
talking about what it what it means to
really look at the human condition from
a rational but also open-hearted
perspective and Peter and I started
talking and I told him that I I was
thinking that I might have a theory of
everything that I should debut and I
think he probably you know haircut the
possibility that what I was saying was
true but then I was invited to give
these lectures at Oxford the Simoni
special lectures in ammonia that the
named after the Simoni who went to space
also created Microsoft Charles Simoni
yeah I think he was like the original
engineer at Microsoft and and he had
endowed a professorship in at Oxford
where which was held is held now by
Marcos de Soto after Richard Dawkins
held it which has some lectures attached
and I was invited to give lectures under
this program and it you know I was
giving technical talks but a story or
two came out about how a potential
theory of everything was being debuted
and I guess Peter probably saw that he
invited me to a quiet conference he was
holding in the South of France and
shortly afterwards and then he invited
me to a breakfast after that and at the
breakfast I think I was midway through
some breakfast sausage and he just
blurts out he says you have to leave New
York I didn't understand why and I said
it really and go where he says you could
come here and I said and do what and he
said you could work for me so I didn't
know whether he was like suffering from
too much sleep but it turned out he was
quite serious and
it's been one of the most rewarding
intellectual relationships of my life
he's just a stunning sparkling mind and
somebody who has not only the courage of
his convictions but has been right so
many times and over enough things that
he has had the freedom to break with all
tradition when he thinks the world is
wrong and one or two people may have it
right which is that's exactly my cup of
tea did he have a clear idea of what you
would be doing when he hired you or made
the offer um I'm probably less important
to him is my guess is is that the first
issue is that there are it's so
difficult to think for yourself I mean I
find it very difficult to think for
myself I have all sorts of ideas in my
head that aren't mine I'm subjected to
all sorts of pressures I find difficult
to resist and so I think Peters looking
for the tiny universe of people who are
attempting to think things through from
first principles and as it's become very
tough because social socially
constructed reality is so much a part of
our lives so I think first you his
feeling would be find the people who are
capable of seeing something really new
and then figure out what to do with him
later escaping the or averting the
consensus reality is that you've
mentioned whenever possible whenever
possible what outside pressures do you
find tempting or difficult to mitigate
oh I mean everybody wants to to be loved
to fit in the the the fear that happens
when you start swimming away from the
shore that you're not going to find a
next Island before your strength gives
out I think it's very rational to be
afraid of thinking for yourself because
you may very very easily find yourself
at odds with the community on which you
depend and I think for some of us is
just a compulsive behavior it's not even
necessarily the smartest evolutionary
strategy it's just it's hard to do it
any other way
hugging the shore well or or not I mean
if you if you if you keep trying to
screw your eyes up so you can see the
world the way other people
people are reporting that they see it
and it just doesn't work you realize at
some point that it's a losing battle you
might Trenton might as well try being
yourself what is the first example that
comes to mind of a time when you had
that fear of swimming away from the
consensus and facing the the scrutiny or
criticism of people in a given community
well sometimes it happens by accident so
I remember for example being in a guitar
store in Philadelphia and having a crowd
of people gather around as I played
something badly and I couldn't figure
out why they would want to listen to
somebody who is not very good at
classical guitar and this isn't like
bragging that I'm great at class I was
really not that good and it turned out
that I had taught myself from sheet
music and I believed that the notation
for using your thumb is to use the
letter P which I interpreted as pinky so
I was using my weakest finger for
everything that needed to be done by my
strongest finger and so my guitar was
completely completely wrong and that was
a you know a clear example of well this
didn't come from a guitar teacher it
didn't come from a normal experience
with music came from teaching yourself
something and having the scars to prove
it
so I think in that case you also learn
how much power there is that you you can
shortcut all sorts of things so as you
know you've showed us with Pareto
principles and trying to assume the work
of the 10,000 hours you start to look
realize that the world is meant to be
jailbroken and and then you get into
really scary stuff where you come up
with political conclusions that aren't
shared by others so for example I don't
have the usual convictions of my groups
about immigration I am of the opinion
that what most people think of as
progressive immigration is actually
regressive and so
you know at some point I came out with a
free-market model to open borders but
without adversely affecting American
workers and have you written about that
oh yeah I what was the peer-reviewed
model for how to do it for a layperson
interested in exploring your opinion on
that or your perspective on that is that
would you point them to a given paper or
sure there's one called migration for
the benefit of all in the International
labor review think of 2002 and the funny
thing about this paper is is that it
takes what US corporations always claim
they want which is access to any workers
anywhere in the world and it achieves it
through a market mechanism but
unfortunately what they were really
interested in wasn't the small gain and
efficiency that comes from being able to
hire on a global market they were really
much more interested in the wealth
transferred from American workers to
American business owners and so it was a
great example that they thought they'd
make a free-market argument but in fact
they weren't interested in the free
market advantage they were interested in
transfer payments and so when you give
them a free market model they lose all
interest in the free market which is I
think just really funny you mentioned
guitar I can recall we had dinner at
your house which was not drugs over
dinner was death over dinner where we
talked about you know death and I think
that was somehow related to NPR or some
radio station capital capital radio some
NPR affiliate that's right and we
discussed death over dinner but one
thing I noticed that your home was that
you have a lot of musical instruments
when did you start experimenting with
music and how many musical instruments
have you experimented with am i right
that the federal government hasn't made
musical instruments illegal so I've been
experimenting with musical instruments
for some time v III think it's some
point you learned that music is an
abstraction and that each
particulars just a way to instantiate
the same common abstraction and so this
was extremely powerful for me because
you explain what that what you mean by
that well I don't really hear music very
well I don't have a lot of intuitive
feel for it to me it looks like systems
and the idea that music was so highly
systematized and that this was covered
up by the standard relationship that we
pick up where we take music lessons we
learned to read music in this country
lots of people are bad at reading music
and lots of people embedded following
instructions but you find that in other
areas of the world in which notation
isn't a big part of musical education
people very casually pick up an
instrument and start playing and I think
it's because that's the systems if you
will the math behind the music is so
powerful that it allows you to improvise
it allows you to compose and to
understand that there are canonical
songs at some point for example I wrote
a tiny computer program in Python and
put it in a tweet and it's only purpose
was to reproduce the chord progression
for Pachelbel's Canon as an algorithm
did you say Taco Bell no I can't believe
that that I've heard that correctly okay
I thought I said Pachelbel's killer
there we go all right yeah now when
you're talking about the ability to
improvise pick up an instrument and
start playing I mean Paul McCartney I
believe is is one example that I thought
oh he's such a gifted intuitive musician
I'm not that I heard and this could be a
completely off base that he at least for
a period of time couldn't read music and
is is that because humans have
potentially some type of innate grammar
that they are for music in the same way
they might have some type of innate Lang
innate language grammar like along the
lines of a Chomsky and his and his
theories or is it something else I think
you're right I mean I think that it it
comes down a lot of it to the physics of
a vibrating string or air column so if
you look at the harmonic
the patterns of vibration that are
encoded into simply taking a catgut and
stretching it between a wall and the
ground and then twanging it there seen
my spot room in other words that so much
of our musical system is in the math and
in the physics of a vibrating string
there's really you know there's one
crazy innovation which is even
temperament which the West figured out
which has to do with a strange math fact
that if you raise the number two for
twice the frequency which gives us the
octave to the 19th power and then take
the twelfth root thereof that's almost
exactly equal to three and that weird
numerical accident is what makes it
possible to both have extremely
beautiful intervals but have them also
so regular that you can do harmony and
and make chords and I don't think most
musicians probably even know why we use
a 12-ton system it's real and that's
what you just described before the
12-ton system that's even temperament
yeah that's Paul so I've always been
somewhat insecure as it relates to music
I've never thought I was how interested
in neatly capable of being good with
musical instruments and I grew up trying
a lot of musical intruments and quitting
them whether it was piano trumpet etc
the drums is our one example or
exception rather where I've I have so
much fun playing even poorly that I will
continue to practice on the flip side
though how many if you had to just take
a stab how many how many different
instruments would you say you've toyed
around with in one capacity or another I
would say that the the ones that I
regularly check in with would be
mandolin harmonica guitar piano and
occasionally some funkier stuff than
that and you've but you've also dug into
natural human languages yeah what
languages have you in the past I think
oh well
oh gosh um I mean the ones I love sure
Turkish and Indonesian were great fun to
learn about and learn some of Russian is
extremely emotional but grammatically
unfairly unforgiving
I enjoyed the little bit of Thai that I
started trying to learn because tones
are not a big part of any of the other
languages that I've tried but when I
tried a little bit of Vietnamese the
tones were so hard that there was no
satisfaction I spent three weeks and I
couldn't say my first word convincingly
why do you and I promise this is going
somewhere oh not that it has to but why
well it's a question I get asked often
times is why do you study these
languages that don't seem to have any
practical application in your life how
would you answer them like Turkish for
example mmm there was a girl Indonesian
same answer well Indonesian is is just
brilliant
it's everything that can go right with a
language for a u.s. language learner has
happened to Indonesian so for example
it's not inflected for tense if you want
to say I came you would say I already
come right right so you if you wanted to
it's not injected for inflected for
number so if the word for child is a
knock the word for children is a knock
squared or a knock yeah what I'm going
on or on wrong which person person yeah
those people wondering automaton man of
the forest very good
so in them it's in a Latin script and so
I would say that if you wanted to figure
out your bang for your buck with a
language
try Indonesian if nothing else has
worked for you you may find that you
have over a hundred million new friends
and a facility you never thought you
could develop Indonesian super cool I
remember spending a month in Bali and
just drilling down into it and it was
such a relief after studying languages
like Mandarin which similar to
Vietnamese is just so unforgiving if you
don't get the tones right you could have
a vocabulary of five thousand words and
no one will be able to communicate with
you in any meaningful way I think also
when you try one of these languages
that's less common to learn people are
so much more appreciative than if you're
yet the enth person they've met who's
trying to speak French yeah the psychic
payback and the gret the gratitude that
you get is a factor that I think is
undervalued expedia Spanish is X because
I could travel to Y number of countries
and talk to Z number of people and say
well that might be true but if you say
go to Greece as I did at one point and
pick up 20 different lines and make sure
you throw in two or three that are kind
of ridiculous just for comedic effect
you're the sort of added value to your
save vacation there will be a hundred
extra versus say a 2x with Spanish
ompletely agree and that makes it so
much fun Turkish oddly enough and we
won't for those people who are not
interested in languages we're not gonna
spend the entire time talking about
languages but I'm gonna try to tie this
into music Turkish for instance and this
is pointed out to me by Turk is
grammatically extremely similar to
Japanese it's really really weird I mean
eerily similar so it was very easy for
me to start to pick up Turkish from
having spent time as an exchange student
in Japan and so there brings up all
sorts of interesting theories about
migration patterns and so on from long
long ago but what does if anything
studying music have in common with
studying natural languages because the
latter is where I'm more comfortable
even though I thought I was bad at
languages until you know halfway through
high school yeah I think that
these areas of that are so intrinsically
human and we don't even realize that
there are these systems that are
undergirding it I think that there's at
least that as a formal similarity where
you know until until Chomsky and his
thoughts on grammar we didn't understand
the way in which this could be
potentially an innate process just the
way the you know the hairs in in your
ear and in the organ of Corti you know
may predispose you to love particular
intervals you know when you hear wise
men say you know that's really going
from the fundamental frequency to
three-halves times that frequency back
to the fundamental frequency and if you
can hear the difference between that and
going to two times with a bit of it
somewhere I can't do that very well but
you know these iconic intervals are
really based on physics if you think
about your phoneme production the
wedding production yeah so that sounds
that you can make with your mouths are
really based on a five dimensional
lattice which I didn't understand don't
understand that either I'll need to
explain well you could you can either
turn your nasalization on or off you can
have your vocal cords vibrating so
vocalization can be on or off so those
are two degrees of freedom you can have
your lips in one of several positions a
third degree and then Chinese retroflex
that's a hard one there you go so
instead of saying NASA's imma cheat oh
[ __ ] that up hold on nos I'm assisting
like in Taiwan and go to Beijing they
say not sure if I'm sure cheating that
like I see sounds very like Bengali and
Portuguese with the Chevy shy and they
love doing that anyway not to interrupt
so that's three degrees of freedom and
then you have where on the on the tongue
on the pen the what location on the roof
of the mouth your tongue is attempting
to make contact and how how raised or
lowered it is and so these five degrees
of freedom generate the phonemes and if
you ask you know opera singers to sing
in a really squirrely language that they
don't know like maybe they know Italian
and French but they don't know Hungarian
they may be able to produce all of these
sounds because they've been forced to
understand exactly what the degrees of
freedom are to produce the sense even if
they don't know what they mean right
they have the the conscious awareness
and control of oral articulation never
used that before but much like a say
ballerina with a vocabulary of different
types of pirouettes and and movements
would be able to replicate a lot of what
you would find in tango because they
have this this vocabulary and awareness
as a side note for people who might be
wondering Japanese people have a really
tough time learning almost any foreign
language because they have a very
limited set of phonemes in their
language
so they kind of got short changed when
you know God was handing out sounds and
which is why I say with with R and L you
know they have not ebu data as opposed
to R or L but as soon as you point out
to them the position of the tongue like
la you touch the tip of your tongue to
the back of your teeth then all of a
sudden just like a snap of the fingers
they can figure it out but no one's ever
tried to explain it to them they're just
like repeat this sound repeat this sound
but once you explain that that one
factor and you're like no no touch your
tongue to the back of your teeth like oh
I got and of course it takes practice to
do quickly but that is why Japanese have
a very tough time with almost every
language Spanish maybe one exception
let's let's come back to something you
said earlier which is navigating from
first principles exciting this is a
really important concept to understand
what what does that mean I think that
and why is it important well very often
we have some spectrum of difference that
we're allowed frequently in politics or
news somebody will talk about the
Overton Window what can we discuss what
can't we discuss yeah Overton Window the
Overton one you mean in the context of
say a debate or a news flash so for
example when Donald Trump said that he
wanted to temporary
really ban Muslims from entering the
u.s. that was considered outside the
Overton Window it was not something that
was discuss about and I think that a lot
of us may benefit from the Overton
Window this idea that we're going to
make certain ideas too hot too dangerous
for people to express employ company but
on the other hand what we've started to
do is to hamstring all the cognitive
power in our contrarian thinkers where
they don't feel comfortable or safe
thinking aloud
somebody tells you for example or asked
you the question do you believe
intelligence is perfectly even evenly
distributed between genders or among
ethnic groups statistically it would be
crazy to say yes I believe it's
perfectly distributed on the other hand
socially it would be crazy to suggest
that it isn't perfectly distributed and
so we have all of these really funny
situations where the top-down thinking
tells us what's acceptable and what
isn't but the bottom-up leads us to ask
all sorts of questions that are framed
out if you will by the usual terms of
discussion and I think that this is you
know this is really animating a lot of
people who feel that social justice
which they always thought was a positive
is starting to metastasize into kind of
a thought police where yeah well it's it
seems to have turned into this sort of
internet lynch mob version of
McCarthyism and there you go and
actually I'm gonna put this out there
cuz I was I was thinking about writing a
blog post about this but blog posts take
a long time to write so I'm just gonna
there's a term that I currently isn't
much of a penalty for labeling people
whatever it might be fill in the blank
mist and so you can be accused and
guilty until proven innocent of being
sexist racist fill-in-the-blank
misogynist whatever it might be classist
you name it
that can be really damaging to people
who are accused of such things often
with no evidence or very questionable
evidence or even contrary evidence and
so what I was hoping is there should be
a term that you can apply to people who
go on these witch hunts and apply these
labels and I was thinking that bigoted
ear could be a good one that's good what
do you think so that therefore like if a
journalist let's just say is taking the
lazy route for cheap applause I eat
cheap pageviews right and they're just
accusing people of being these really
career damaging things like sexist or
racist whatever that they themselves
could then be labeled a well-known
bigoted ear for instance and then there
would be some type of social consequence
which I don't see currently to acting in
such a haphazard and damaging way so
currently we have this other weird term
sjw for social justice warrior so I like
bigoted ear why don't we try it in the
wild and see what happened yeah I'd love
that too to hear anyone's thoughts on
this bigoted ear and then I thought a
lot about this because I figured you
needed a term that was sort of
phonetically similar enough for just
like mouth phonemes like phonetically
similar enough to an already loaded term
yeah so that people would immediately
get the negative connotation like you
can't being called a bigoted ear even
though I as far as I know it hasn't
existed can't really be a good thing I
mean you have like bigger than any of
the tier of in most people's minds
associate with racketeering or something
else but does a decent job of kind of
describing the the sin against
intellectual honesty that is you know
what we're talking about this type of
out-of-control
so social justice warrior ship but I
agree with you that it's I think that
even more than top down this the
phenomenon is is so puzzling in a way
because it seems like people are
creating prisons of their own making and
in creating these lynch mobs or
participating in them you're creating
this momentum for this type of activity
that ultimately has to come back and
bite you in the ass or it
just create these barriers to honest
communication and it ended sorry I'm
like up on my soapbox now that we
brought up this stuff it also seems like
and I'd love to hear your opinion on
this but the oftentimes the most
important conversations to have are the
most uncomfortable that would fall
outside of this Overton Window well by
definition and even the conversation
that you most want to have to try to
remediate the long-term problem is
prevented by the evident relish that
some bigoted ears if you will the the
relish that they obviously enjoy and
take for themselves in sort of taking
settling for the short ride rather than
really trying to get some kind of
structural change and I think that
because the level of distrust is so high
in the u.s. at the moment we have a
problem that people are trying to shut
down conversation because they just
don't know where it's going to go and so
as soon as anyone starts talking about
something sensitive you you know you can
always try it out check your priveledge
or something that doesn't even have to
be it can be completely content
independent because you know everybody's
enjoying some privilege at the moment
and so if you're spending all of your
time checking and you're probably not
going to be able to say much of anything
so I wanna I want to shift to a very
serious topic and that is kung fu panda
oh boy keep getting waiting it's getting
weighty now I recall visiting the
offices of Steel Capitol and we had a
fun lunch chat with with a whole group
of folks and I remember going to your
office and seeing all sorts of toys
various types and then a I guess a
figurine of Kung Fu Panda what is your
relationship to Kung Fu Panda this is
this is emotional embarrassing and
rather weighty but I I went reluctantly
I did I can't say that I relished going
to a children's film even though I had
to
kids who were excited to see it but my
wife said it would be a good idea and as
I sat there in the theater I got deeper
and deeper into the story and when the
film was finally over I found myself
weeping and the prettier kids okay with
that I don't think anybody was okay with
that it was it was a little weird and
what I realized was that it was the only
film that I'd ever seen that struggled
with the issue that I felt almost
defines my my quest which is why can't a
self teacher leave pupils and if you
think about that for a second you
realize that Einstein wasn't successful
in leaving any Einsteins
and Francis Crick didn't leave Francis
Crick's and Winston Churchill didn't
leave any Winston Churchill's if there
was some way for a Newton to leave in
Newton dependably the world would be a
completely different place and what kung
fu panda was trying to do in my opinion
was to struggle with this question of
how would an innovator leave a successor
when it's his time to go and at some
point somebody on Korra asked a question
you know this sort of story doesn't make
any sense to me how does a panda slob
become the ultimate kung fu warrior and
I wrote up my explanation and the thing
is probably the most viral thing I've
ever written what is that what is the
title for people who and will link to
this in the show notes for everybody
just for our work we calm /li it's how
does PO become an awesome kung fu
warrior in the film Kung Fu Panda
something like I'm sure if we look up
your name in Kung Fu Panda it'll pop
right up
and so my claim was that the original
innovator in the film is is a turtle
which is an even more inappropriate kung
fu archetype than a panda because
they're obviously slow-moving and the
turtle works out the
of harmony and focus at the pool of
sacred tears but when the kingdom is
threatened by a kung fu student of great
ability who's gone wrong all that the
kingdom can muster is the usual
collection of over trained students so
think aspirants to Princeton and
Stanford and Harvard and so these are
all the kids we get like perfect SATs
and have amazing extracurricular
activities but fundamentally what we
don't realize is that they've all been
rendered incomplete in a way because
they can't tap into the self teaching
modality because they have been so
thoroughly over taught and so the turtle
recognizes that the Panda is the only
one who can save the day and all the
turtle has to go on in choosing a
successor is that the Panda has
innovated one silly thing which is to
turn a fireworks cart into a makeshift
rocket to jump a wall and so from this
humble beginning the magic unfolds and
it's it's really about the magic of how
one self teacher leaves a successor and
solves the problem have you come to any
conclusions or beliefs outside of that
essay that related to how autodidact or
Newtons can leave Newton's when they
travel on from this world I think so I I
can't prove it but I think where I'm
headed with this is that most of us who
wind up using these sort of strange high
agency hacks to negotiate the world have
some kind of a traumatic birth that we
may flatter ourselves that were in touch
with reality but in fact reality is a
second best strategy if you're lucky
your family works pretty well and you
never leave social reality it's only
when something goes wrong that you
discover okay the world doesn't work in
any way the way I was told here's the
underlying structure and what you then
have to realize is
if you want to do this at scale you've
got to stop relying on these traumatic
births it's like you're waiting for
somebody to get bit by a spider to
become spider-man now you have to do
this as a more controlled fashion
you have to harvest spiders that's right
you've got it you've got to regularize
it so I think what we need to do is we
need to create a completely second
secondary parallel educational structure
for people who are going to be in the
high agency creativity discovery in a
idiom and realized that we know how to X
in part expertise but we don't know how
to impart creativity in genius what do
you could you define high agency sure
high agency or just explain what you
mean by it well I think what I mean is
are you constantly when you're told that
the some but something is impossible is
that the end of the conversation or does
that start a second dialogue in your
mind how to get around whoever it is
that's just told you that you can't do
something so how am I gonna get past
this bouncer who told me that I can't
come into this nightclub how am I going
to start a business when my credit is
terrible and I have no experience you're
you're constantly looking for what is
possible in a kind of MacGyver sort of a
way and that's your approach to the
world uh I'm not gonna take us off the
rails here have you seen the Martian yes
did you love it the ultimate high agency
code I just saw it last night man it was
just like two hours of MacGyver on
steroids I loved it yeah and it I'm glad
you brought it up I think it heralds a
return at least among Americans to our
previous way of being I think there was
some terrible thing that happened
starting around 1970 and that is just
cracking now so really about 45 years
of a low agency super-safe timid
frightened kind of societal aspiration
if you just stay on track can we keep
the American prosperity machine going I
think we now realize that you can't do
it without a bunch of really marginal
characters people who have might be
described as disruptive have bad
attitudes these are my people and
they're tough to deal with and I don't
always and enjoy them but I do think
that without them it's not much of a
football team what can someone do who's
listening to this let's say and they're
they live in a community where that is
clearly low agency and they want to
train themselves to be able to look at
option C D and F when people say do you
want a or B right
or if they're given let's say the the
know from the bouncer from the
admissions officer from the fill in the
blank they look for a way around it
instead of just being stopped in their
tracks
how can someone are there any
recommendations or tools or resources
exercises that they could use to
cultivate that hire agency well there's
I don't think there's a community on
earth where somebody isn't modifying
their car beyond what's street legal I
don't think that there's any community
in which nobody is cooking something up
in the basement that probably is
prescribed by law I don't think that
there's a community on earth where
somebody isn't trying to break into
their own computer in order to see how
it works from the inside so there are
high agency people everywhere what there
isn't necessarily is critical mass and I
think that you know sometimes I refer to
the Bay Area is the innovation ghetto so
you have all of the people who are too
high agency to to behave properly and
wait their turn and the rest of the
country
and so they've been given like the
nicest piece of real estate an ungodly
amount of cash and you know the pleasure
of each other's company but they've been
told you know okay you have to stay at
the terms of your probation so you have
to stay within the bay area and so what
I'd love to see is I'd love to see more
of us violating our parole and going
into the rest of the country and trying
to bring that irreverent spirit because
I think one of the things that the u.s.
still has over let's say a competitor
like China is that we tolerate the
middle finger it is perfectly acceptable
to be disruptive here in San Francisco
where you and I are conducting this
interview whereas if I'm told that my
child is disruptive in Kansas or South
Carolina I'm probably being told that
he's being sent home for bad behavior so
I think it's really important to start
respecting our marginal citizens of
greatest ability and looking for the
unusual personality types that are
irreverent and committed enough to
making things happen and to really do
things what this is gonna seem like a
detour but it might be related what book
or books have you gifted most to other
people oh there's so for my science
friends I tell them to read the Emperor
of sent by Chandler burr about my friend
Luca Turin and it talks about a renegade
scientist being stymied by the journal
nature by various conferences by the
established research centers and it's
just a wonderful introduction to how the
dissident voice is marginalized and
because Luke is such a
a genius of olfaction and chemistry he's
able to take a perspective which may or
may not be true but keep pushing it
forward and battling through it so
that's one of my favorites I have a
another weird recommendation which is
this book Herrick lesion fire laughs I
see if I can smell this bye all right
Herick leishan fire bye bye chakra who
is the guy who effectively shorted
Watson and Crick he told Watson and
Crick that he didn't think that they
were very good and very smart and then
they were sort of they didn't know their
chemistry they they weren't qualified to
work on DNA and it turned out that they
got it right and he got it wrong and
when I heard that there was somebody who
bet against Watson and Crick I thought
well this is just gonna be the laugh of
the century but it turned out just too
short those guys required another genius
and and he writes about trying to
suppress these guys and failing because
they were right and he was wrong and he
has enough presence of mind to struggle
with it so the these are books that I
think are incredibly powerful because
they talk about what it's like to be one
against the many if you were advising
say eh you might hate this question if
you were advising say a senior in high
school non-technical I'm sorry senior in
college non-technical probably too late
probably too late
well let's just say that I mean that was
me right so okay all right and I had you
know fairies and sugar plums in my head
about Silicon Valley and wanted to come
here and attempt to build something
amazing what what books
sources would you suggest or what advice
would you give well first of all if you
can do anything else with your life
other than innovate other than create go
do that don't come if you're still here
listening saying okay I can't really do
anything else me but you have a
compulsion that you cannot resist yeah
but fundamentally you are zagging when
other people are zigging you're not even
thinking outside the box you haven't
seen the box for years if that's who you
are
my feeling is just get here and I can't
promise that your first week or your
first month and a half is gonna be the
greatest week or month and a half of
your life but you will fall in with
people there there's enough open hearted
assistance that's given there's enough
money that there's a different culture
of abundance now that may not last this
but more than this particular cycle but
even if this is a bubble
I think it'll reinf late in the same
place because fundamentally we've run
out of all other options other than
innovation if we don't create and we
don't think our way out of this I don't
think we have a great plan for steady
state so it's grow or die and that means
that we'll have another bubble and
bubbles aren't terrible things a lot of
wonderful things happen during them what
to you is the most powerful idea or few
ideas in 0 to 1 or the material that
helped generate that from moon glass
that Peter taught which was transcribed
by Blake masters yeah well there's so
the entire book is about what to do if
you think you have a secret if you
really understand something the rest of
the world is confused about and it's an
important truth 0 to 1 says he here all
the ways you might want to make that
work I think the problem is the average
person has never had an idea a really
powerful personal idea and so most
people don't have a single secret and so
the real reason most people shouldn't
start a company is that they don't know
or believe anything that the rest of the
world knows the thinks of as being
nonsense right and so this is this is
the engine behind the book and what's
disturbing is to watch people reading
this book not realizing that it's the
whole thing is predicated on you hat you
must have a secret and try to imagine
somebody building a car with no engine
it doesn't really matter how nice you
get the upholstery it's not going to
work now I there I suppose are different
schools of thoughts here as with many
different domains some people would say
well you either have the hard wiring to
come up with these secrets or spot these
unpopular opinions or on propagated
opinions that very few people are no
other people hold then there are the
folks I tend to lean this way who think
that that can be facilitated right by
and forcing people to ask for instance
absurd questions and so if you had to
10x not just 10% increase but like 10x
your output in whatever it might be how
would you do it and forcing people to
break whatever systems they might have
in place right the current incremental
approach to what they're doing these
minut optimizations won't answer the
question right they have to delve into
this kind of Terra incognito things they
haven't explored do you think this can
be do you think it can be taught there
you can help people to get better at
spotting or or coming up with these
these secrets seeing things that other
people don't see
well
yeah I do and I think that in part this
is why it's so difficult coming back to
the sort of kung-fu panda pedagogy
question assumed that I hit one or two
of these secrets and I am successful at
them doesn't have to be in business
could be in science could be in
literature anywhere the problem is is
that you want to lead someone through
the process of succeeding at something
and seeing what blocked what blocked the
path and what do you mean by that
well here's a problem I give people okay
if I'd solved it then in fact nobody's
solved it was getting sort of free
Mackenzie nu jitters okay how many golf
balls can you fitness this is exactly
what I hate about those problems is if
the if there are answers in the back of
the book it's not a good problem it has
to be an actual problem that the the
asker doesn't know so I don't know how
to solve the problem of the umbrella
there's nothing I like about umbrellas
they have seriously Tim they blow up in
wind so that they're easily wrecked
under the conditions that they're
supposed to be in which they're supposed
to be used they have these long metal
spikes at about eye level so they're
clearly a safety hazard your legs always
get drenched there you go everything
about the umbrella strikes me as wrong
now what I believe is is that there are
and I've seen people try to innovate in
the umbrella situation there are ones
that have air blowers that blow the
water away from you there are funky
folding designs but I am almost positive
that there exists some very simple
mechanical design that would improve the
umbrella on the other hand I don't have
that same confidence about the coffee
mug yes you could put some electronics
in it you can make it smarter than it is
but fundamentally it seems to be in such
a simple stay
that I wouldn't think that I should
innovate there so if I can give the
example where there is a solution known
luggage before 1989 just going to ask
you about this all right so it turns out
that nobody really knew how to do
wheeled luggage before 1989 it was just
mind-blowing yeah anyway yeah it's well
it's hard to imagine that like the whole
world had their Wedd their heads wedged
so far up there that they couldn't think
to put in these large recessed wheels
with a telescoping handle and this was
the invention of a guy named Robert
Plath I was a pilot for Northwest I
think and in one fell swoop he convinced
everyone that their old luggage was
terrible so even though there wasn't a
lot of growth he created the growth
because nobody wanted their old luggage
and you know you could compare these
discrete brainwave innovations across
field so for example in in table tennis
in the early 50s the worst player on the
Japanese team at the Bombay Table Tennis
Championships was this guy hiroshi sato
j-- who and he glued two foam expanses
to both sides of a sandpaper the table
tennis bat and nobody could cue off of
the sounds because it changed the sound
of the ball it's like a silencer round
exactly it's like if so if you put a
suppressor on your paddle suppressor
just like that you use that word makes
me think that you have a bunch of
firearms hiding in your basement but
anyway I can either confirm is it but
but the the the idea that the worst
player on one of the lower rated teams
would be the undisputed champion simply
through an innovation that was that
profound shows you what the power of one
of the eye these ideas is that the power
laws are just so unbelievably in your
favor if you win
that it makes it worthwhile or dick
Fosbury who went backwards over that I
don't 68 you got it very good ridiculed
and then mimicked and eventually
standard yeah so in the case of say the
the umbrella or the luggage is there a
process for trying to tackle and
innovate in these areas along the lines
of something you might find it's a an
idea or exercises that you guys do at
teal capital when looking at different
markets or trying to assess say an idea
and its its validity or promise in a
market are there any particular
questions I guess is what I'm asking
that you find very useful when trying to
spot these these breakthrough ideas well
it depends in situation by situation so
for example in science I try to use
various intellectual arbitrage
techniques where if you have a bunch of
smart people have been focused on a
problem I try to look at what as a group
their weaknesses are where how how how
is the their bread buttered what is it
that they can't afford to say or think
what might be an example well so for
example in in in theoretical physics
there all sorts of shibboleths where if
you can't say that you believe that
quantum mechanics is intrinsically
probabilistic you're not a member of the
club because it's assumed that you sort
of can't accept a difficult reality or
if you can't sign up for one of the
major schools you have no way to get
funding because you there's no one who
will support your grant applications so
you start to look at what causes what
should be a diverse portfolio of ideas
to collapse in terms of the diversity
where everybody starts representing the
same point of view with tiny variations
if you're looking at a problem that's
never been attempted you don't want to
use intellectual arbitrage because
it's just blue sky there's no reason
that the first attempts to think through
the problem won't yield fruit but you
know in the case of the umbrella I would
start to think about well what made what
made me think or what made one thing
that this was a problematic object so
count the number of moving parts then in
general as things reach final form they
they tend to get radically simple so
there's too many moving parts if there's
some innovation that's happened since
the problem was originally considered so
for example in the case of oculus rift
and virtual reality
maybe virtual reality was considered
years before oculus but nobody had
rethought it in the presence of
economies of scale that bring the
screens and smartphones down in price
and so suddenly you have the high
quality screens that are affordable that
way back when would have cost
prohibitive amount so ask yourself
what's changed recently where is the
object that currently inhabits the space
violating some sort of aspect of
canonical design what do you mean by
canonical design well you know let's
look at nature if I look at the there's
a great back great virus called t4
bacteriophage and if you look it up it
looks like a lunar lander it's really
cool and the genetic material is held in
a capsule called the capsid that has the
form of an icosahedron and so you wonder
something with some sides xx side there
we go 20 sided platonic solid second
what's a dodecahedron 12 goddammit all
right they're dual to each other I might
need to brush up on my Dungeons &
Dragons dye references ok so please
cancel crazy to think that before Plato
ever existed nature had figured out this
complicated 20-sided object
but because it was so natural at a
mathematical level even if it was
complex nature found the canonical
design even though there was no
canonical designer there was no God
given because it was a god-given form it
didn't need to be funk up if you will by
any individual or the recent discovery
of grasshoppers that use gear mechanisms
for jumping you would think we'd
invented gears but in fact gears are
such a natural idea that natural
selection founded long before we did so
is is this natural idea than roughly
synonymous with canonical or is that
yeah it does have a different
connotation I mean I I sort of think
about it if we get visited by aliens
from another planet we're pretty
advanced they're gonna know about
platonic solids they're not going to
call them platonic solids because they
didn't have Plato and in fact they were
known before Plato but these forms that
really don't have a an inventor so much
as a Discoverer got it these are things
that just sort of have to be mm-hmm okay
I took I took us down the rabbit hole a
little bit but we're talking about
umbrellas yeah and the number of
elements are moving pieces is a medium
that is a clue that something is wrong
right right right it's not as elegant as
it should be so I would I would for
example immediately think about you know
let's say the Japanese and their love of
origami and the mathematics of paper
folding that would be a place that I
might see whether I could mine that silo
of expertise for any application to the
umbrella very often it's a question of
being the first person to connect to
things that have never been connected
before and that's something that is a
commonplace solution in one area is not
thought of in another so I think that it
involves recognizing when something is
likely to allow an innovation figuring
out where the information
might be and as a last resort thinking
really hard about what the form of the
solution might be before you actually
push yourself to be concrete I think
very often you see people get very
impatient with hand waving oh that's a
lot of hand waving for my tastes well if
you stay practical you'll probably be
part of a lot of incremental
improvements but you may never be part
of one of these moments where that idea
changes everything I was reading a quote
today I'm blanking on this philosophers
first name last name
Dennett maybe you know Daniel you know I
wanted to say that and then I said and
then I thought to myself that's too much
like Daniel Tammet who's the subject of
this documentary called brain man but I
think it is Daniel and I'm gonna butcher
this but he said something along the
lines of people look down upon those who
say it seemed like a good idea at the
time but that is actually a sign of of
brilliance in some capacity because
you're able to look back and admit that
and have that type of self-awareness and
I apologize Daniel if okay this mostly
wrong but what would you think if you
had to create a class for any grade
level from ninth grade to the end of
college what would the class be and when
would you teach it well I'm gonna go
grab a copy of this quote that's gonna
bug me but I'm listening
okay so it's a really interesting
question part of the problem surrounds
where would I be allowed to teach this
class so first where you like well the
first question is are you really allowed
to deeply question your teacher or your
school yeah so I would I would look to
for example the Milgram experiment and
the Asch conformity experiment
so in the Asch conformity experiment one
person was led into a room and asked
simple questions which a bunch of
Confederates of the experimenter
Confederate
those people cooperating with the
experiment right agreed to answer the
question and under its effect yes the
actors answer the question in an
obviously wrong way and then when it
comes time for the only real participant
to answer the question
they often falsify their answer just to
fit in so you should be able to pass the
Asch conformity test and then there's
the Milgram obedience experiment where a
an experimenter appeared to ask the only
participant to administer a series of
increasing electric shocks and it's
really important that most people
continue to administer the shocks even
when they heard screaming from the actor
in that case if they were assured that
it was expected of them and that they
would not be held responsible and so I
think what you're always looking for is
you're looking for an education which
makes students unteachable by standard
methods and this is where we get into
the trouble which is we don't talk about
teaching disabilities we talk about
learning disabilities and a lot of the
kids that I want that's so true I think
what you're good right apart are kids
who have been labeled learning disabled
but they're actually super learners
they're like learners on steroids who
have some deficits to pay for their
superpower and when teachers can't deal
with this we label those kids learning
disabled to cover up from the fact that
the economics of teaching require that
one central actor the teacher be able to
lead a room of 20 or more people in
lockstep well that's not a good that's
not a good model and so what I want is I
want to get as many of my dangerous kids
out of that idiom whether it requires
dropping out of high school dropping out
of college but not for for no purpose
drop into something start creating
building join a lab skip college don't
so this would be
that was the program is it the it's not
20 under 20 the scholarship program that
Patil fellowship the teal fellowship
could you describe that for people who
are in how can you describe that in
brief and then does that is that an
example of what you're describing or is
it different well so a lot of there's a
lot of confluence between how Peter
thinks and how I think even though we
start from radically different places
the teal fellowship pre-existed my
coming on and it's a program that will
pay kids a hundred thousand dollars over
two years to leave college to try
something like start a company or a
non-profit or do something of high
agency and roughly speaking a lot of the
kids drop out of the Stanford's and
Princeton's and Harvard's they're
incredibly impressive and we're not that
worried that in life they're going to be
set back because they're gonna do just
fine under any circumstances and they
get now in fairness to the most of those
schools will allow them to come back
that's true but two years is a little
bit longer than it's comfortable a lot
of people understand that there's a gap
year but one of the things that we hope
is is that if they do go back they will
go back maybe as graduate students that
maybe the undergraduate degree is
unnecessary in fact we at some point did
a little study and we found that for
every advanced professional degree we
could think of there was somebody who
held that degree who had never gotten a
BA or a BS and so the idea of skipping
college is now quite appealing to me and
with the idea being that a master's
degree or a PhD or a JD or an MD has an
embedded assumption of a BA or a BS but
in fact you'll never be asked about that
lower degree because the the leading
degree the professional degree
credential is usually the one that
matters now what would you say to those
out there who might
look at your credentials and say well
how would you have been able to obtain
these very helpful degrees from places
like Harvard and Oxford if you hadn't
had the prerequisites set by going to
undergrad well I guess I would imagine
they're critics who would say there's a
there's a survivorship bias sure you
hear about the zuckerberg x' but you
don't hear about the 999 other people
who might drop out but then end up
feeling or being restricted in their
career options because they can't show a
college degree that at least is a common
refrain so what would you say to those
people what's so my undergraduate wasn't
from Oxford was from Penn and there was
their language requirement the
University of Pennsylvania and I at the
time couldn't figure out how to satisfy
it so I assumed that I would not
graduate from Penn and then I just broke
all the rules they had a program that
actually helped you break all the rules
if you could find it and what we and I
have to ask what what did that look like
so it looked like one guy his name was
Mike Zuckerman he was a professor in the
history department and he's what we
would call in Yiddish a shtarker he's
the guy who breaks kneecaps for his
people she taka daka
it's like German you know like strain
like the stronger and stronger and so
every time I would like sign up for a
class that had a prerequisite and I
would be kept held back he'd get on the
phone he'd say I understand your hold
this is Mike Zuckerman at the office of
university scholars I understand that
you're holding one of my kids hostage
with red tape you know it wasn't like he
had any power but the sound of it caused
other professors to let go and always
his official job he's just like this
history the professor
oh he was okay wasn't just like the
secret mercenary I think in the basement
he this was a brilliant idea that he
thought up and it was sort of a secret
kind of a secret program so you didn't
know that it was there and it had power
it allowed you to I think immediate
access to any of Penn's graduate school
is the program called university
scholars so it sounded respectable it
sounds very respected right and it was
just a anti red tape program for kids
who wanted to do research while
undergraduate and it was created by this
history
yeah amazing yeah and this shows you
what you know all through corporate
America and and and and the Ivy League
universities there are rebels who can't
quite leave these institutions but I
call it the core the rebel end of
corporate and the corporate end of rebel
so I end up as the corporate end of
rebel but I've always had help from the
rebel end of corporate and he was a guy
who was the rebel end of corporate rule
end of corporate he was the maverick
within the machine that's right let's
switch gears a little bit because for
this part one I have to get to the
airport shortly so I want to ask a
couple of my favorite questions that are
short questions that you don't have to
give short answers to but we'll see what
we can knock off when you think of the
word successful who's the first person
who comes to mind and why Paul Dirac
because he found what must be the
strangest and most bizarre piece of
physics I ever hoped to encounter how do
you spell his last name D IRAC Dirac I
don't know why I put a weird Turkish
back on his name I just really wanted to
what else can you say about him that
leads you to call him successful is it
is it just that discovery or is it the
way you went about it you know there
were so I'm very focused on physics into
the 20s and and in physics in the 20th
century there were really three guys who
were the main forces behind the three
major equations and what I noticed about
all three of them Einstein Dirac and a
guy named Seon yang is that they all
followed the same weird path which was
to use aesthetics rather than experiment
as their guide so the entire rest of the
field has had to use experiment and be
in a regular science idiom and these are
the three guys who more than anyone just
sort of closed their eyes and tried to
figure out
how should this game go and then prove
that the world more or less went the way
they said it should now by aesthetics do
you mean looking for what they perceived
as beautiful or elegant no all right so
the this is like the you know I have to
make this joke that the scientific
method is the radio edit of great
science great science doesn't look much
like the story you've been told about
people diligently trying to falsify
things and in all sorts of statistical
significance great science looks like
breaking into graveyards and digging up
bodies when you know you shouldn't or
trusting your aesthetic sense when the
data tells you otherwise
and and I've always loved this aspect of
Sciences it's that you may want to tame
this thing and it won't be tamed it will
always be the case that the leaders of
the field are the misfits in the back
throwing spitballs rather than the good
kids who are always there on time
raising their hands we asked about books
earlier so we won't hit that do you have
a favorite documentary or movie besides
kung-fu panda or any that come to mind
well there was a brilliant one that I
haven't heard ever heard of since I saw
it called rated X which had the great
idea it X yes and it was about
pornographers and it was an anti
pornography movie and it's it's gambit
was to just let pornographers talk at
length without interruption or editing
and so it made its point by just giving
these people a mic when they really
shouldn't have said anything I thought
that was absolutely ingenious I really
want to watch that yeah sometimes the
the best sort of refutation and debating
tactic is just letting somebody talk
just let them bury themselves what $100
or less purchase has most positively
impacted your life
in recent memory last six months a year
whatever I just bought my punk
ten-year-old kid a mandolin and suddenly
that's all we hear in the house and I
just think what a completely bizarre
instrument to fall in love with and I
think I got it for 98 bucks just on my
it's a hair's breadth away and why the
mandolin
as opposed to a different instrument you
know I think it's really important like
we're talking about with older with with
languages that are less commonly studied
I think that the mandolin is the loser
of an old battle between the mandolin
and the guitar it was very popular at
the end of the 19th century when a bunch
of I think they were called like the
Italian students or the Spanish students
came through and everyone went crazy for
mandalas but they weren't quite as
versatile it's the same fingering
patterns as a violin so that everything
that you learned to pluck you can then
learn to bow later but it's also compact
and it's highly melodic in its nature so
you cannot alternate between court it's
like a little bit of a ukulele on
steroids do you have any favorite
mandolin player oh gosh well there's
this this guy just got the McArthur
fellowship that I can't think of his
name of course I'm imagining I can't be
that many mandolin playing MacArthur
winners maybe hoorah
but I guess have you surged you know the
Marco Marco Connor who was the great
bluegrass prodigy first a violin I think
he won the fiddle championship three
years in a row they outlawed him ever
winning again so he became the
flatpicking champion on guitar I think
he's pretty terrific what was Mark
O'Connor mark O'Connor
so the MacArthur award this is the Oh
this is another this different person
yeah the cards are worthless people not
familiar it's actually a cool word worth
looking into that's called the genius
grant yeah do you have any particular
morning rituals that are important to
you okay each morning is basically a
struggle against a new day which I view
is a series of opponents who must be
defeated I'm not a morning person so
every morning I get out of bed I'm just
astounded that I've done you've gotten
on your feet well you know there was a
was a Julian Schwinger the great Harvard
physicist I think was asked if he would
teach the 9 a.m. quantum mechanics
course knee he stopped for a second mmm
the person who was asking said what's
the problem professor srini says I don't
know if I can stay up that light so what
if you are trying to do deep creative
work that requires a lot of synthesis or
just as a vol my rava cop might say
orthogonal thinking and so on
what would your what would your kind of
work psycho I'm like when do you do that
type of work so I use a weird technique
I used coprolalia where I say since it
sounds pornographic a little bit it's
you know those strings of obscenities
that Tourette's patients involuntarily
utter sure so I was long term I think
it's coprolalia cavalierly coprolalia
okay I've got it like just talking
streams of [ __ ] yeah so I find that when
we use words that are prohibited to us
it tells our brain that we are
inhabiting unsafe space and it's it's a
bit of a sign that you're going into a
different mode so I tend to become sort
of facultative ly autistic that is I
think I can be social and personable if
I'm trying to do that but when I I'm
going to do deep work very often it's
kind of very powerful aggressive energy
to it it's not easy to be around it's
very exacting and I think I would
probably look very autistic to people
who know me to be social
were they ever to see me in work moment
so how do you how do you incite that how
do you know that so do you just going
back to the expression that I still
honor the term I still can't say do you
just start trying to string together as
many as sanity's as possible I have like
I have my same seeing limitation it's
like an invariant mantra that I have to
say can you share it or don't know no
one's top secret is like it's and you
can't share your meditation like TM yeah
exactly how well just some hints then
how long is it probably takes me 7
seconds to say it oh my god the
curiosity is killing right but but it
starts to you have to you have to decamp
from normal reality where you start
thinking about everything in positive
terms well how am i negatively going to
impact my neighbor no your this is your
time you're stealing the time and it's
you know the act of creation is itself a
violent action what time of day would
you typically bring up this this mantra
and going to that mode well if give a
preferred time sure there's a so this is
a politically incorrect statement but
mathematicians of an older generation
discussed the hour of the night when all
theorems are true and all women are
beautiful that the pleasure of doing
math or physics at 3:00 a.m. when the
phone stops ringing when you have no
FOMO because everybody's asleep it's a
Monday night and it's just you in an
expansive whiteboard that's when the
magic happens
yeah unfortunately for my social life
that's also when I do mind not saying
it's good but my best writing and
synthesis happens yeah is that right
yeah it's it's typically between 1:00
and 5:00 a.m. I find five stuff I come
up with is a little bit unreliable five
is only if I've managed to catch the
wave how nice the wave you've been
waiting for for
an entire season of mess or thing and
you're like okay there's no way I can
paddle in now and miss that set that's
coming and you just have to to ride it
at least i what i will do is ride it
until i just collapse from exhaustion if
i have it if the muse is somehow been
captured in the bottle i mean i'm a
cycle over 24-hour I mean not go to
sleep in that state but you know that's
what that's rare it's not you have to
yeah it is rare for me also not to
compare the the funny how-to stuff that
I write to complex physics if you could
have one billboard anywhere with
anything on it what would it say one
billboard anything on it just because a
large number of well credentialed
experts believe something in common
doesn't mean that it's necessarily wrong
but if they've reached consensus that's
the way to bet some somehow people have
to learn that consensus is a huge
problem if there's no arithmetic
consensus because it doesn't require a
consensus but there is a washington
consensus there is a climate consensus
in general consensus is how we bully
people into pretending that there's
nothing to see you know move along
everyone and so I think that in part you
should start to learn that when people
are people don't naturally come to high
levels agreement of agreement unless
something is either absolutely clear in
which case consensus isn't present or
there's an implied threat of violence to
livelihood or self
what advice would you give to your 30
year old self and if you could just
place us in time what were you doing at
that age so when I was 30 I guess I was
still struggling to stay in or get out
of academics and I think what I didn't
realize is that the structure of the
universities was that they were either
hitting steady-state or growing very
very little or shrinking and that was a
not a healthy place to be because most
of the good seats in the musical chairs
competition had already been found in
the 60s and they had occupants and we
were in some sort of a game where we
were doing work for the system but we
weren't set to inherit it and I think
what I needed to do was to decamp and to
realize that technology was going to be
a boom area and even though I wanted to
do science rather than technology it's
better to be in an expanding world and
not quite in exactly the right field
than to be in a contracting world where
people's worst behavior comes out and
your mind is grooved in defensive and
rent-seeking types of ways that I just
life is too short to be petty and
defensive and cruel to other people who
are seeking to innovate alongside you in
the last question maybe the last of more
- that doesn't make any sense but now
here we go do you have any ask or
requests for my audience for people
listening anything they should think on
do or otherwise well first of all I
would really like a high-quality
umbrella from one of you just to prove
the point that was actually a reasonable
problem to set I guess what I would
really like is for those of you who've
been told that you're learning disabled
or you're not good at math or that
you're terrible at music or something
like that
seek out unconventional ways of proving
that wrong believe not only in
yourselves but that there are structures
that are powerful enough to make things
that look very difficult much easier
than you ever imagined that is great
advice and for those people there who
particularly have this music and
security as I do one thing that is
seemed to me like a life raft and the
sea of complexity is the the 3 chord
song by the axis of awesome work words I
knew I was gonna do that
four chords on there we go so you can
look that up on YouTube or elsewhere for
a real hilarious but also potential
potential what the hell am i trying to
say here I just ran out of caffeine this
is the moment no it's sort of like it's
a it's an amazing act that they put
together which shows you how complexity
can be created through simplicity or /
or perceived complexity well yeah and it
shows you that your mind has stored over
a hundred songs that you think of as
being completely different in different
places even though there was a simple
fact draw bringing them all together you
know III liken it to the moment that
people realize that in it almost every
advertisement for wristwatches the
watches are set to ten ten and before
you realize that you can't really
believe that it's true but afterwards
you realize that the world has just
pulled one over on you because ten ten
looks like a smile to watch advertisers
I guess it's very symmetrical isn't it
yeah but it what's funny is is that
isn't that the wisdom has crept into the
to the point and sometimes you'll see
digital watch ads and they'll still be
set to tens that even though it doesn't
look like a smile
so I'm gonna I'm just gonna throw out a
teaser here because we don't have time
to get into it today but you and I have
privately spoken quite a bit about
psychedelics I am either by the time
people hear this or very shortly going
to be helping to raise funds for a very
interesting study that Johns Hopkins is
putting together you said to me not too
long ago something along the lines of
you'd be amazed or you wouldn't believe
how straight Nair I was for so long when
was the first time that you tried
psychedelics relatively recently and it
was because I was I had been
propagandized so thoroughly that even to
this day I don't like the Association I
don't like the word cloud around them
there were all sorts of confusions that
the power of one of these substances
must come from killing brain cells like
pouring acid on your brain and leaving
it as Swiss cheese it wasn't until I
started meeting some of the most
intellectually gifted people in the
sciences and beyond and I realized that
this was sort of the open secret of what
I call the hallucinogenic elite whether
it's billionaires or Nobel laureates or
inventors and encoders that a lot of
these people were using these agents
either for creativity or to gain access
to the things that are so difficult to
get access to through therapy and other
conventional means so tune in next time
when you'll hear Tim say I will dig into
this into this font of knowledge this
gold mine and give a Google guys search
my name and Johns Hopkins by the time
you hear this you might see some very
interesting stuff up about this and you
could actually get involved and learn a
lot more about it but before that and in
closing I suppose I should ask where can
people find you on the end
where can they ping you if they want to
share with you their incredible origami
umbrella solution
that's a good question I'm on Twitter or
wherever you might be more than less yes
I'm on Twitter at Eric our Weinstein and
you can find some of my essays at edge
org particularly one on professional
wrestling as a metaphor for living in it
constructed and false reality well Eric
I love hanging out this is always so
much fun and I appreciate you taking the
time to join us and to brainstorm and
share your wisdom with me and with
everybody listening thank you so much
Tim thanks for inviting me into your
world and allowing me to talk to your
base alright folks so let us know you
think definitely say hi to Eric at Eric
our Weinstein
say hi to me also if you have any
feedback if you'd like to hear around to
at tea Farris TFE our Riss on Twitter
and until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs
is a great partner for creating and
growing your business it's a one-stop
shop for all of your graphic design
needs whether that's a logo website
business card or anything else I use 99
designs to get book cover prototypes for
the 4-hour body which went on to become
a number one New York Times bestseller
and I also use them for banner ads
illustrations and other things with
99designs designers around the world to
compete to create the best design for
you you give feedback and then pick your
favorite you end up happy or you get
your money back it's very simple you can
check out a few of my own designs and
those of yours meaning Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs com forward slash
Tim and right now my listeners you guys
will get a free $99 upgrade on your
first design that's 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth run so the question is why why is
it so popular why is it unique because
you can get services previously reserved
for the ultra wealthy but only pay
pennies on the dollar for them and this
is because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront com forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than ten asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have
on the podcast but I've been so
impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
now I do have to read a mandatory
disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there's the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealthfront comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
Tim and until next time thank you for
listening